[Music]
nonsense
a penitentiary is not intended to be a
place for coddling and pampering those
who have broken the law
stevenson chairman of the prison
commission waved a fat hand in the
direction of the convict
standing at the foot of the table this
man
he went on has learned in some way that
the newspapers are gunning for the
warden
and he is seizing the opportunity to
make a play for sympathy on his own
behalf
i'll admit that these tales he tells of
brutality toward the prisoners are well
told
but i believe that he is stretching the
facts they can't be true
discipline must be maintained in a place
like this even if it requires harsh
measures to do it at times
there is no call for brutality however
exclaimed the convict
breaking the rule that prisoners must
not speak unless they are spoken to
then ignoring the chairman's upraised
hand he went on
we were treated like beasts here if a
man so much as opens his mouth to ask a
civil and necessary question
the reply is a blow dropping a knife or
fork or spoon at the table
is punished by going without the next
meal
men too ill to work are driven to the
shops with the butts of guns
petty infractions of the most trivial
rules mean the dark cell
and a diet of bread and water do you
know what the dark cell is
solitary they call it here hell would be
a better name
steel all around you steel walls steel
door
steel ceiling steel floor not a cot to
lie upon
not even a stool to sit upon nothing but
the bare floor
and darkness not a ray of light ever
penetrates the dark cell
once the door is closed upon you no air
comes to you
except through a small ventilator in the
roof and even that has an elbow to keep
the light away from you
is it any wonder that even the most
refractory prisoner comes out of their
broken
broken in mind in body and spirit and
some of them
go insane stark staring mad after only a
few hours of it
and for what i spent two days in
solitary because i collapsed from
weakness at my bench in the shoe factory
see this scar he pointed to a livid mark
over one
eye a guard did that with the barrel of
his rifle
because i was unable to get up and go
back to work when he told me
he knocked me senseless and when i came
to i was in solitary
insubordination they called it two days
they kept me in there
when i ought to have been in a hospital
two days of hell and torture
because i was ill people pray to
reforming men in prison
it's the other way around it makes
confirmed criminals of them
if they don't go mad first the chairman
wriggled in his seat
and cleared his throat impatiently we
have listened to you for quite a while
my man
he said pompously but i for one have had
enough
a dozen or more prisoners have testified
here today and none of them has made a
statement to back up the charges you
have made
and why demanded the prisoner because
they were afraid to tell the truth
they know that they would be beaten and
starved and deprived of their good time
on one excuse or another
if they even hinted at what they know
you wouldn't believe them anyhow
you don't believe me yet i probably
shall suffer for what i have said here
but that doesn't matter they can't take
any good time away from me
i'm in for life his voice grew bitter
and that is one reason i have gone into
this thing in detail
for my sake and the sake of others who
cannot look forward to ever leaving this
place
the law has decreed that we shall live
and die here but the law said nothing
about torturing us
this board guaranteed its protection to
all who were called upon to testify here
answered the chairman it has no desire
to whitewash any person in connection
with the investigation which is being
made
and in order that there might be no
reflection upon the manner in which this
hearing is conducted
neither the warden his deputies nor
guards have been permitted to attend
unless you have tangible evidence to
offer us and can give the names of those
who can back up your charges
you may go just a minute it was the
board member nearest the prisoner who
interrupted
then to the convict you said i believe
that only
a few hours in the dark cell often will
drive a man insane
yet you spent two days there you are not
insane are you
no sir the convict spoke respectfully
my conscience was clear and i was able
to serve my time there without breaking
but another day or so would have
finished me you testified against me at
my trial didn't you
i hold no grudge against you for that
sir i give you credit for doing only
what you thought was your duty
your testimony clinched the case against
me yet i am innocent
the chairman wrapped sharply upon the
table i utterly failed to see what all
this has to do with the matter under
investigation
he protested irritably we are not trying
this man's case
the courts have passed upon that he is
just like all the rest
any one of them is ready to swear on a
stack of bibles that he is innocent
let's get on with this investigation the
convict
bowed silently and turned toward the
door beyond which the guards were
waiting to conduct him back to his cell
a hand upon his arm detained him mr
chairman
said blaylock the member who had
questioned the prisoner
i request that this man be permitted to
go on with what he was saying
i shall have no more questions to ask
you were saying
he prompted the man beside him i was
saying that i was innocent
resumed the convict i was about to add
that not even a man who was guiltless of
wrongdoing
would be able to withstand the terrors
of solitary for any length of time
you for instance are a physician a man
of sterling reputation
against whom no one has ever breathed a
word yet i doubt that you could endure
several hours in the dark cell if you
would only try it
you would know for yourself that i have
spoken the truth
gentlemen i beg of you to do all in your
power to abolish the dark
cell men can stand just so much without
cracking
and if you will dig into the facts you
will find that nine times out of ten
it is men broken and solitary who are
responsible for the outbreaks in prison
that is all he bowed respectfully and
was gone
clever talker that fellow commented the
secretary of the commission
breaking the silence he almost had me
believing him
who is he blaylock you had him summoned
i believe
the physician nodded i confess it was as
much from personal interest in the man
as from any hope that he might give
valuable evidence here
he said he surprised me with his
outburst
he is a clever talker ellis is his name
martinellis and he comes of a splendid
and well-to-do family
university graduate and quite capable of
having carved out a wonderful career
but he was idolized at home and given
more money than was good for him
it made him an idler and a young
nerdywell
but whatever he did he did openly and i
never heard of anything seriously wrong
until he was convicted of the crime
which brought him here
murder i suppose stevenson the chairman
was interested in spite of himself
he spoke of being in for life yes
killing a girl agnes keller was her name
poor but well thought of church worker
member of the choir and so on it was
brought out at the trial
in fact ellis told it himself that he
was infatuated with her
and they were together a great deal not
openly of course
because old man ellis his father would
have pawed up the earth
the affair ended like all these
clandestine affairs
especially if the girl is young and
pretty and poor
it was the theory of the prosecution
that when she discovered her condition
she became frantic and demanded that
ellis marry her
the alternative being that she would go
to his father with the story
it was charged that he killed her to
avoid making a choice
the evidence against him was purely
circumstantial but the jury held it was
conclusive
ellis admitted on the stand that they
often went riding in his motor car at
night
one damning fact against him was that he
was seen driving
alone and rapidly along the country lane
near where her body was found
he had nothing to back up his claim that
he felt ill and went for a drive in an
effort to relieve a sick headache
of course he denied absolutely that he
was responsible for her condition
or that he even knew of it but the jury
was out less than an hour
the only hitch i learned later was
whether to affix the death penalty or
not
he said you're a witness against him
what part did you play
ask stevenson an unwilling one
answered blaylock quickly i did not
believe that ellis was guilty then
i'm not convinced of it now but as the
girl's physician
and presumably one of those to whom she
would go in her trouble
i was questioned as soon as the coroner
had held an autopsy
i admitted that she had confided in me
and that i had agreed that the man
responsible should marry her
she did not tell me his name but my
evidence added weight to the theory that
ellis killed her to avoid marrying her
the door to the room swung open and the
warden stood on the threshold
may i come in he asked dinner is almost
ready and i thought i'd better give you
warning
he crossed to an empty chair and sat
down
we concluded the taking of evidence
quite a little while ago
said the chairman since then dr blaylock
has been entertaining us with the story
of the crime of that fellow martin ellis
he was one of the witnesses quite
unusual
yes the sheriff who brought him here
told me all about it answered the warden
he's hard to handle had trouble with one
of the guards a while back
and we had to discipline him two days in
the solitary cell on bread and water
wasn't it
asked blaylock he didn't have any good
word for it the warden flushed
few of those who taste of it do he
admitted
too much a matter of being left alone
with your thoughts and your conscience
they'll punish you as much as anything
can well
suppose you take an adjournment and come
on to dinner will you want to make the
regular inspection tour of the prison
oh sure yawned the chairman undoubtedly
everything is alright as usual
but if we admitted it the newspapers
would have something to howl about
he rose and with the rest of the
commission trailing them
followed the warden to the dining room
well
let's make the inspection and have it
over with stevenson suggested when the
meal was finished
where do we go first warden through the
shops and smaller buildings first
then the cells that way you'll end up
closest to the administration building
and you can go back into conference with
a lease delay
uniformed guards stood smartly at
attention as the warden piloted the
commission through
trustees ingratiatingly hovered about
the party eager to be of service
great steel barred doors swung open at
the approach of the commission
and clanged noisily behind it the
afternoon sunlight slanting through the
bars
relieved the somberness of the cell
blocks and revealed them in their [ __ ]
and spannedness
made ready for the occasion well
everything seems to be okay
said the chairman as the party again
drew near to the offices
anyone else got any suggestions
yes i'd like to see the dark cell
answered the secretary
i don't recall ever visiting it and that
fellow ellis interested me
he said it was a pocket edition of hades
where is it warden
the ward assumed a jocular air you'll be
disappointed
he warned it's down in the basement
where prisoners who want to do so can
yell and scream to their hearts content
without disturbing anyone
a trifle dark of course but if to some
it is hell
it is because they choose to make it so
if you really want to see it come ahead
it's not occupied however he did not
mention that he had seen to that
with all this uproar about the
management of the prison
it wasn't safe to take chances the
commission he had foreseen
might decide to make a real
investigation and you never could tell
in just what condition a man would be in
after several hours in solitary
there you are gentlemen he said with a
flourish of the hand when a trustee had
switched on the lights in the basement
not one dark cell but half a dozen
he stood back as the members of the
commission crowded forward
and peered into the dark recesses over
each doorway
a single electric bulb shown weekly far
too weakly for the rays to penetrate
into the corners
the solid bolt-studded doors stood open
formidable
and forbidding any of you want to try it
ask the warden from the background sure
let blaylock take a whirl at one of them
suggested the secretary
his conscience ought to be clear enough
not to trouble him
go on doctor try it and let us know how
it feels
i do it myself but i don't dare risk my
conscience
blaylock standing just inside the
doorway of one of the cells
turned and for a moment surveyed them in
silence
your suggestion of course was made in
jest he said
but a sudden ring came into his voice
i am going to take you up on it no
as a chorus of exclamations came from
the others
my mind is quite made up warden i want
this
as realistic as possible you will please
provide me with a suit of the regulation
convict clothing
well of all the blamed fools exclaimed
the chairman
then he gave his shoulders a shrug go on
and get a zebra suit warden
i only hope this doesn't get into the
papers
a trustee was dispatched for the striped
suit when it had been brought
blaylock already had removed his outer
garments amid the banter of the others
he did not deign to answer them until he
had buttoned about him the prison jacket
and jammed upon his head the little
striped cap
i guess i'm ready he said then you
gentlemen have seen fit to ridicule the
experiment i am about to make
but i say to you that i'm doing this in
all seriousness
i do not believe that solitary is as bad
as ellis pictured it to us
i am going to find out warden you will
please see that conditions here are made
exactly like those which surround a
prisoner in this place
he whirled upon his heel and strode into
the cell
how long do you want to be left in there
ask the warden 15 minutes or so
ellis declared his belief that i could
not stand it for an hour or two
came the reply from the depths of the
cell suppose that we make it two hours
at the end of that time you may return
and release me but not a minute before
very well number 9982 replied the warden
you are now alone with your conscience
the heavy door clanged shut and a faint
click told blaylock that the light above
the door had been snapped off
then the sound of footsteps growing
fainter and fainter
the clang of the door leading to the
basement then
silence blaylock was alone
feeling with his hands he made his way
to a corner of the cell
and sat down upon the bare hard floor
he shut his eyes and set about
concentrating his mind upon some subject
other than the fact that he was a
prisoner of his own free will to be sure
but a prisoner nevertheless he always
had prided himself upon the fact that he
had the ability to drive from his
thoughts at will
all topics but the one which he desired
now he chose at random to begin
preparing an outline of a lecture
which he was scheduled to deliver within
two weeks before the convention of
medical men
back home in his study blaylock was
accustomed to stretching out at length
in an easy chair
his feet upon a stool a pillow beneath
his head
here his legs were stretched out upon
the floor at right angles to his body
held bolt upright by the steel wall at
his back
he sought to relieve the strain by
keeping his knees in the air
but the floor offered no firm foothold
and his heels slipped
irritated blaylock slid away from the
corner and tried lying upon his back
his eyes staring up into the darkness
above him
immediately that position too grew
irksome and he turned over upon first
one side than the other
and finally he got up on his feet and
leaned against the wall
thus another 15 or 20 minutes passed he
judged
he found that it was impossible to
concentrate his thoughts
so he resolved to let them wander
leaning against the wall
speedily proved uncomfortable and
blaylock began to pace around and around
the narrow confines of the cell
four paces one way two at right angles
then four
then two it reminded him of a big bear
he had once watched in a zoo
striding back and forth behind the bars
but never very far from the door
which shut him off from the outside
world in freedom
suddenly blaylock discovered that he had
made the circuit so many times in the
darkness that he was turned around
that he did not know at which end lay
the door to the cell
he began to hunt for it feeling with his
sensitive surgeon's fingers for the
place where the door
fitted into the wall of the cell it
annoyed him
after making two trips around that he
had failed to locate the door
he could tell by counting the corners as
he came to them
the door fitted into its casing so well
that he could not distinguish it from
the grooves where the plates of the cell
were joined together
immediately it became to him the most
important thing in the world
to know where lay that door he thought
of sounding the walls to see if at some
point they would not give back a
different sound
and thus tell him what he felt he must
know
it was becoming a mania with him now so
gently
he began wrapping with his knuckles
against the steel here
there in one place then in another
then he tried it all over with his ear
trained to detect even without the aid
of a stethoscope
the variations in the beating of a human
heart pressed close against the walls
but again he was foiled every spot
gave forth the same hollow sound
angered blaylock kicked viciously
against the incense at steel
shooting pains in his maltreated toes
rewarded him
and with a growl of anguish he dropped
to the floor to nurse the injured
members
then he became aware that his hands were
stickily saturated
and he knew when he discovered that his
knuckles were skinned in raw
that it was his own blood desperately he
fought to regain his self-control in an
effort to force himself to be bland and
unruffled
when the warden should come to release
him as blaylock felt sure would be the
case in only a few minutes at most
he caught himself listening intently for
the footsteps of the warden
or some trustee or guard sent to release
him
he strained his ears to catch the
faraway clang which would indicate that
someone was coming into the basement
but only the hissing sound of his own
breath broke the tense silence
funny he thought how very still things
could be
it required no very big stretch of the
imagination to picture himself
as really a recalcitrant prisoner
slapped in solitary to ponder upon his
misdeeds
going further he recalled a story which
he had read long ago
of a man who found himself to be the
only living human being
the others having been wiped out in the
flicker of an eyelash by some mysterious
force
why didn't the warden come on and let
him out of here surely the two hours
were up and he was getting tired of it
it would never do however to be caught
in this frame of mind when he was
released
he must emerge smiling and ready to give
the lie to that clever talker ellis
once more he got up and began his
circuit of the walls
he felt that he was master of himself
again and it would do no harm to try to
solve the puzzle of the door that would
not be found
perhaps the warden had been delayed by
some unexpected happening
oh well a few minutes longer wouldn't
make any difference
suppose that he were in ellis place in
for life
he didn't want to think of ellis but
somehow the face of the lifer
kept obtruding itself his face and his
words
what was it that ellis had said you for
instance
are a physician a man of sterling
reputation
against whom no one ever breathed a word
yet i doubt if you could endure several
hours in the dark cell
and the warden had added that in the
dark cell a man was alone with his
conscience
damn that warden where was he anyhow
blaylock began to dislike him perhaps
there was something in those stories of
brutality which the newspapers had
printed after all
dislike for the warden began to give way
to hate
blaylock wondered if the warden and that
fat pompous little stevenson
chairman of the commission hadn't got
their heads together and decided it
would be a good joke to let him stay in
there
a great deal longer than he had ordered
he would show them
once he got out that he didn't relish
that kind of a joke
that he wasn't a man to be trifled with
thus another hour passed as he reckoned
it
and his anger and passion got the best
of him
he kicked the walls and hammered upon
them with his clenched fists
insensible to the fact that he was
injuring himself
then came fear fear that he had been
forgotten
suppose that there had been an outbreak
in the prison that the convicts were in
control
would they release him might they not
wreak their vengeance upon him in the
absence of another victim
he began to call moderately at first and
pausing often to listen for some
response
then louder and louder until he was
screaming without cessation
he cursed and swore pleaded and cajoled
threatened and sought to bribe by turns
demanding only that he be taken from
this terrible place
he was dead to the fact that it was
impossible for anyone to hear him
that only the reverberation of his own
voice thunderous in that narrow place
answered him beating down from the
ceiling
thrown up from the floor cast back into
his teeth by the walls
the noise of his own making overwhelmed
him crushed him
stark terror held him in its icy grip
now
his thoughts pounded through his brain
like water in a mill race
the perspiration fell from him in
rivulets as he hammered and smashed at
the walls
his brain was a fire he began to realize
that what ellis had said
very easily could be true men did go mad
in this place why he was going mad
himself
mad from the torture his body was
undergoing mad from being alone with his
own thoughts
there were more lucid moments when
reason desperately sought to assert
itself
blaylock's cries became less violent and
moaning and sobbing softly he began all
over again that endless circuit of the
cell
in search of the door failing he raved
again
and staggered from wall to wall or
leaped madly toward the ceiling
as if by some miracle escape might lie
in that direction
exhausted at last he sank to the floor
poignantly conscious that interminable
nights and days were passing over his
head
and that thirst and hunger keen and
excruciating
held him in their grasp at intervals
strength would come back to him strength
backed by indomitable willpower
that sent him lunging to his feet to
renew his battering at the walls
his frenzied shouts and screeches in
just one more
effort to make himself heard his
knuckles were broken and bleeding
his lips cracked and swollen his voice
came out shrilly from his dry and racked
throat his body and legs were succumbing
to a great weariness that would not be
denied
came the time at last when his own voice
no longer dined into his ears
when his legs refused to obey the will
that commanded them to hoist him upon
his feet
when he no longer could lift his hands
his spirit was broken at last
and he gave up the struggle and sank
back upon the floor
and all around him the darkness shut
down the darkness and the silence
[Music]
then the door was thrown open and framed
in silhouette against the light beyond
stood the warden got enough doctor
he called out cheerily your two hours
are up
why don't you answer me dr blaylock
what's wrong man he peered into the cell
in a vain endeavor to force his eyes to
penetrate the darkness
failing he fumbled in his clothes for a
match and with hands that shook
scratched it against the door then his
face went white as a sheet
he staggered where he stood and the
match burned down to the flesh of his
hands and scorched it
for in the far corner he had perceived
flat upon its
back a haggard blood-stained
white-haired thing
that winked and blinked at him with
vacant eyes and
muttered and gibbered incoherently
reason came back to blaylock one day
many weeks later
he opened his eyes with the light of
understanding in them
and they told him from his surroundings
that he was in a hospital
outside the sun was shining brightly and
in a little park just beyond
birds were singing and the breeze
brought him the sound of children at
play
awake at last are you asked the white
capped nurse who came into the room just
then
yes said blaylock and a rasping whisper
he did not know it then but the calm
soothing voice he had once boasted was
his best asset in a sick room
was gone forever the terrific strain to
which he had put his vocal cords and his
peroxisms in the dark cell
had shattered them you're doing
splendidly
the nurse assured him brightly you've
been seriously ill
but you're recovering rapidly now no
said blaylock positively as one who
knows
i shall never get well give me a mirror
please
i don't believe there's one handy she
evaded loathed to let him see the havoc
in his face
but he insisted please he begged
i am prepared and i do not think i will
be overcome
i will be brave reluctantly then
she started to place the silvered glass
in his hand
as he reached out to take it he stopped
his hand halfway
the hand he was accustomed to see with
its tapering fingers and well-kept nails
the hand that so deftly had performed
delicate operations
was gone instead was a slim
claw-like thing with distorted knuckles
and joints
blaylock finally extended it took the
mirror and slowly but steadily
brought it into line with his eyes he
had expected some changes
but not the sight that greeted him the
black wavy hair
had given place to locks of snowy white
his face was drawn and wrinkled and
lackluster eyes stared back at him from
cavernous sockets
long he gazed at this apparition then
silently he let the mirror fall upon the
cover
and closed his eyes don't take it so
hard doctor
begged the nurse you've been through a
harrowing experience and your face shows
it now
but in a short time the lie did not come
easily
and her tongue faltered never mind that
whispered blaylock it doesn't matter now
send for stevenson please
the chairman of the prison commission
came without delay
compelling himself to conceal the
repulsion he felt at the sight of the
broken man upon the bed
he bustled in with forced pleasantries
stevenson said blaylock when finally the
other had taken a chair
and the nurse had withdrawn i have
something to tell you
that day i went into the dark cell now
now old man
sue stevenson laying a restraining hand
upon the other's arm
don't let's talk about that we abolished
it that very day
why bring up that awful experience of
yours no one knows about it but the
commission
the warden and your doctor and nurse
here we all are pledged not to talk
about it
and the newspapers didn't have a lie
except that you were taken ill
let the past take care of itself
blaylock old man and let us talk of
other things
a flash of the old willpower is shown in
the sick man's eyes
no he said firmly no stevenson
the past cannot take care of itself bend
closer stevenson
i must tell you something and it seems
i'm not strong enough yet to talk out
loud
that day i so boastfully demanded that i
be locked up in solitary
i thought i knew myself and my willpower
i believed that i had such control over
my mind and my body that i could defy
any torture man might devise without
quailing
despite the knowledge that my conscience
was not the lilly white thing i had led
others to believe it was
for stevenson my conscience was black as
black as hell
it held the knowledge of a great sin on
my part a huge
wrong that had been done to another but
i had stifled it by my willpower until i
believed that a thing that was dead
that could never throw off the bondage
to which i had doomed it
and arise and accuse me it was to prove
that i was superior to it that i
deliberately chose to be locked up with
it
where alone with my thoughts i could
prove myself the master once and for all
for martin ellis had shaken my
confidence
where before i had been certain i was
doubtful i wanted to prove him a liar
and at the same time satisfy myself that
i was a free man
and not the galley slave of that thing
which we call a guilty
conscience in that cell that conscience
which i believed i had killed
rose up to show me it had but been
sleeping
under other conditions it might have
slept on indefinitely
in there it overwhelmed me with a sense
of its power
and made me feel that i was about to
meet my god without even so much as a
veil behind which to hide my guilty
thoughts
no matter which way i turned i saw an
accusing finger
pointing at me out of the darkness and
the solitude was shattered by a voice
which cried out that those who sin must
pay and pay
until the slate is wiped clean and i had
sinned
but i had not paid conscience is a
terrible thing
once it is aroused stevenson it is
living
vibrant and it lashes and scourges until
it has exacted its toll
that was what it did to me there in the
darkness alone and at its mercy
and with no chance to escape and in my
agony and fear
i cursed the god who had created me and
saddled me with this thing
i learned my lesson though before i was
through i who had presumed to piece my
own puny will above the great eternal
will
i who had dared to believe that the
great order of things the plan by which
we all must live and die
must make an exception of me learned
that i was wrong
martinellis is innocent stevenson and i
trust to you to see that justice is done
he did not kill agnes keller and i knew
it
and i stood by and let him be convicted
more i took the stand against him and
helped make that conviction certain
i told only the truth in my testimony
but i did not tell all i knew
and what i omitted would have saved
ellis i did not want to testify at all
but the prosecution refused to let me
take advantage of the confidential
relation which is supposed to exist
between physician and patient
the state was right in its theory that
the man who strangled agnes keller did
so because he was responsible for her
condition
and did not wish to marry her she came
to me in my study
on the night she met her death and told
me she had discovered she was about to
become a mother she refused to take any
steps i suggested
and she said that her child when it was
born must have the legal right to bear
the name of its father
and that very night she was lured into
an automobile with a promise that the
man who was to blame
would take her to a nearby town and make
her his wife
but on that lonely country road he
turned upon her and killed her with his
bare hands
and how do i know these things because
stevenson
i was the man responsible for her
condition and it was i
who killed her
[Music]
if every one of the 60 guards and
officials at the granite river prison
had been asked for the name of the most
popular guard on the force
there would have been 60 answers asa
shores
if each of the 1500 convicts in the
prison had been asked which guard was
the most disliked by the convicts
1500 answers would have been the same
asa shores
if some curious person had asked of each
convict in each guard
who is considered the most desperate the
hardest the shrewdest criminal in the
prison
the answer would have been unanimous
malcolm hulsey
the lifer true it does not seem
reasonable that assassin's shores should
be liked by every guard and official
and disliked by every convict to those
not
familiar with the duties of prison
guards it would seem that assassir's
method of handling the convicts
if disapproved of by 1500 convicts
would surely be disapproved of by at
least one of the 60 guards
but the explanation is simple asashore's
great-great-grandfather
had followed the prisons as mariners
follow the seas
then assa's grandfather took up the work
and followed it
with an iron hand and inflexible will
until one day a cell-made knife in the
hands of a long-time khan
entered his back at a point where his
suspenders crossed
deviating enough to the left to pierce
his heart
came next ossa shores father who went
down and attempting to quell the famous
stromberg break of 1895.
asa therefore his prison methods
impelled perhaps by heredity
looked upon every wearer of gray behind
the walls as a convict
nothing more nothing less he neither
abused nor
favored any convict a one-year man was
to assa
a convict and no better than the man who
was serving a life sentence
the crime for which any convict was sent
up was of little moment to assa
neither did he bother about who among
the inmates was considered desperate
the fact that a man wore prison gray was
sufficient
whether he be a six-month sneak thief or
a 99-year murderer
when assa shot and killed richard mutt
allison
when the latter attempted to escape the
warden had said
there was really no need of killing that
half-witted short-termer assa
he was doing only a year and was
perfectly harmless
a shot in the leg or foot would have
been better
and asa's reply had been i had no idea
who the man was
though i have seen him dozens of times
and i did not know how long he was doing
but it would have made no difference if
i had known he was a convict sir
and he was attempting to escape if he
was only half-witted as you say
he should have been in the insane asylum
not in the penitentiary
so that was that assa ever gave a
convict a smile it had never been
recorded
it is a known fact that he was never
seen to frown upon a convict
he was in short the smileless unyielding
personification of duty
and every convict hated him for what he
was
when asa shot he shot to kill and he
never missed
four little white crosses on the bleak
hillside near the prison
proclaimed his flawless marksmanship
why was this big sandy-haired
steel-blue-eyed middle-aged ossa shores
liked by his brother guards there were
many reasons why
it was as if foss's unnatural cold
vigilant
unfeeling attitude toward the convicts
was offset each day
when he came off duty by a healthy
wholesome desire to drop duty as a
workhorse sheds an irritating harness
he was the life of the guard's quarters
a big good-natured playful fellow
who thoroughly enjoyed a practical joke
whether he be the victim of the joke or
the instigator
if he had a temper he had never allowed
it to come to the surface
he excelled in all sports in the
gymnasium and somewhere
somehow he found more funny stories than
any other man on the force
the trait old saying that he would give
a friend the shirt off his back
fitted him like a new kid glove he gave
freely to his friends
and in giving seemed to find real joy
after 12 years service on the guard line
asa was still an ordinary wall guard
this would seem discouraging to many but
not so to assa
it was not generally known that he drew
a larger salary than did the other wall
guards
he was an excellent wall guard hence he
was kept on the wall
while newer men on the force were
promoted to better positions
but asa drew the salary of a shift
captain and was therefore content
he did not even seem to mind when he was
taken from comfortable tower number one
morning shift and detailed permanently
to tower number three
on the graveyard shift at night from 8
pm to 4 am
this change was deemed necessary for
several reasons
first because assa positively refused to
discriminate between
short-termers and long-termers or
desperate men and harmless nuts
when using his rifle to stop a break or
the attempt of a single convict to
escape
the men being locked in their cells at
night asa as a night guard
would have little opportunity to
practice rifle shooting with a running
convict as the target
another reason for detailing him to
tower number three
was because trouble was expected some
night at that point in the yard
and with surefire assa on the job the
officials felt that any attempt at the
convicts to escape would be promptly
frustrated
one of us wholesome habits when no
convicts were near
him was singing it was not singing
really but asa thought it was and he
shortened the long lonesome hours at
night on tower number three with songs
song rather because he knew and sang but
won
it was not a late or popular song and
aza sang it it sounded like the frogs
that croak in the marshes at night
when i die and am buried deep i'll
return at night to take a peep
at those who hated me i'll haunt their
homes and spoil their sleep
chill their blood the skin will creep on
those who hated me
not a pretty song nor did it make
cheerful those guards who passed near
tower number three
while making the night rounds but assa
loved that song
it was while the wall was being extended
another 200 feet to make room within the
enclosure for a new cell house
that assa shot the lifer malcolm halsey
the end wall extending from tower number
three to tower number four
had been torn down and the stones moved
200 feet farther south
to be used on the new wall a temporary
barbed wire fence had been erected about
the area in which the convicts worked on
the new wall
extra armed guards were stationed at
intervals of 50 feet outside the
enclosure to guard the working convicts
malcolm hulsey had successfully feigned
illness one day and was allowed to
remain in his cell
house guards had seen him lying in his
bunk only the top of his head showing
above the blankets
at lock-up time the cell house guards
making the count
saw a foot protruding from under the
blankets in hulsey's bunk
and what they believed to be the top of
his head showing at the head of the bed
at 10 15 that night the eagle-eyed asa
shores
on tower number three saw a dark figure
slip under the lower wire of the
temporary fence and run
ossa fired once and saw the man fall
then assa to comply with the prison
rules yelled halt
the command of course was needless
halsey having halted abruptly when a
30-30 rifle ball plowed through his
shoulder
after the convict had been carried to
the hospital his cell was opened by the
curious guards
a cleverly carved wooden foot protruded
from under the blankets at the foot of
the bed
several bags of old clothing reposed
under the blankets
and a thatch of black horse hair showed
at the head of the bed
before halsey left the hospital the new
wall was completed
tower number four across from tower
number three
had been torn down and a new tower
number four built on the new corner of
the wall
200 feet farther south on the other
corner across from new tower number four
was new tower number three old tower
number three
was left standing until further orders
assa shores remained on the graveyard
shift on old tower number three
while off duty one day assa prowling
about inside the walls
met malcolm hulsey the lifer was still a
bit pale and worn from the gunshot wound
one thing i'd like to have you explain
mr shores said halsey
you plugged me in the shoulder then
yelled halt
why didn't you command me to stop before
firing
well it was this way halsey assa replied
unsmiling and looking the convict
squarely in the eye
i aimed at the spot where i calculated
your heart ought to be
but the light was poor and i had to
shoot quick
i naturally supposed you were dead when
i commanded you to halt
and believing you dead i could see no
reason for being in a hurry with the
command
sorry i bungled the job that way but my
intentions were good
but the scowling lifer persisted you
haven't told me yet why you shot before
commanding me to halt
oh that asa drawled with a deprecatory
shrug of his massive shoulders
that is merely a matter of form with me
i very often after shooting a convict
yell halt sometime the next day or week
besides if you had a nice chance to bump
me off you wouldn't say beware mr shores
i'm about to kill you
for a half minute convict and keeper
gazed into each other's eyes
i get you halsey finally said and i
guess you're right
i have an idea though that my turn comes
next mr shores
and there'll be no preliminary command
or argument
fair enough halsey assa replied as he
turned away
at last the big new cell house was
completed
also wondered whether he would be left
on old tower number three
it had been decided he knew that the old
tower would be left on the wall
but perhaps not used to celebrate the
completion of the new building
the warden declared a holiday and issued
orders that all the inmates be given the
privilege of the yard that day
there was to be wrestling boxing foot
racing and other sports
assassir's sleeping quarters was a low
ceilinged room on the ground floor
in one of the towers of the old cell
house assa had been warned a number of
times that his room was not a safe
place to sleep in the daytime convicts
in the yard could enter the room at any
time during the day
without being seen by the yard guards or
wall guards
though the one door to the room was
thick and heavy asus seldom if ever
locked it
asa had risen in the afternoon
complaining to himself about the noise
being made by the convicts in the yard
his peevishness vanished however after a
cold wash
and he sang as he stood looking out one
of the windows and brushing his hair
when i die and am buried deep i'll
return at night to take a peep at those
who hated me
i'll haunt their homes and spoil their
sleep chill their blood
the skin will creep on those who
assa's song ended then ended in a
horrible gurgle
a trustee found him an hour later lying
in a pool of blood
near the open window his throat had been
cut by a sharp instrument
in the hand of a person unknown
halsey the lifer was questioned of
course but there was absolutely nothing
to indicate that it was he who committed
the murder
the guards looked sadly upon all that
remained of us's shores
and said to each other and hushed voices
it had to come
asa was too good a convict guard not to
be murdered
and though the prison stool pigeons kept
their ears and eyes opened
though each guard became a detective the
murder of asa shores remained a mystery
old tower number three was closed and
the doors locked
there was no immediate use for it but
the warden was contemplating the
advisability of having another guard's
entrance gate cut through the wall under
the tower
in this case of course the tower would
be used again
night captain jesse dunlap sat alone in
the guards lookout
inside the walls at one o'clock on the
morning following the murder of ossa
shores
bill wilton the night yard guard was
making his round about the buildings in
the yard
captain dunlap lazily watched the brass
indicators on the report board before
him
the indicator for tower number one made
a half turn to the left
and a small bell on the board rang the
captain lifted the receiver from the
telephone at his elbow
and received the report tower number one
anderson on duty
all okay dunlap merely grunted a
response and replaced the receiver on
the hook
presently the indicator for tower number
two turned to the left
the bell tinkled and dunlap again took
the receiver from the hook
tower number two briggs on duty all okay
came the report over the wire then
came new tower number three next tower
number four
from the three outside guard posts came
the reports
and one from the cell house each guard
turning in his post number
his name and the usual okay
all the indicators on the board except
that for old tower number three
were now turned captain dunlap relaxed
in his chair
sighed heavily and lit his pipe lazily
his eyes wandered back to the indicator
board
the unturned indicator for old tower
number three held his gaze
and utter sadness gripped him for a
moment
night after night promptly on the hour
he had seen the indicator for old tower
number three
flip jauntly to the left and it heard
the tinkle of a little bell on the board
it had always seemed to him that the
indicator for assassiuore's tower
turned with more pep than the other
indicators that the bell had tinkled
more
cheerily that good old asa shore's
report carried a note of cheerfulness
that lightened the lonesome watches of
the night
now the old tower was cold even as poor
old aso is cold
the doors were locked and barred never
again
thought dunlap would be heard
assassure's familiar song on the quiet
night air
what were the words to that song when i
am dead and buried deep
i'll return at night to take a peep at
those who hated
captain dunlap suddenly sat erect in his
chair
the pipe fell from his lips and
clattered on the floor as his lower jaw
dropped and his eyes opened wide
to stare at the indicator board the
indicator for old tower number three was
moving
moving not with a quick turn to the left
but in a hesitant
jerky way that caused the root of every
hair on captain dunlap's head to tingle
never before had the captain seen an
indicator behave like that
in fact the indicator system was
designed and constructed in such a way
that being controlled by electric
contacts the various indicators would
snap into position when a push button
in each tower was pressed by the guard
on duty in that tower
in short an indicator in accordance with
all the rules of electricity as applied
to the system
must remain stationary or jerk to the
left when the button in the tower was
pressed
but here was indicator for old tower
number three
wavering trembling to the left only to
fall back repeatedly to a vertical
position
then again jerkily hesitantly to the
left
as if a vagrant soul strove to brush
aside the veil that banished it from the
living
captain dunlap sat rigid and watched the
uncanny movements of the bright brass
indicator
vague fleeting chaotic thoughts of
crossed wires
practical jokers wandering souls tumbled
one after another through his brain
if only the bell would not tinkle if it
did ring
well death then though it had taken away
what was mortal of
assa shores had not conquered his
eternal vigilance
and strict attention to duty farther to
the left wavered the indicator
hesitantly uncertainly the bell rang
a weak slow ring it was that sounded
strange and unnatural
in the death-like silence of the dimly
lighted lookout
captain dunlap was a brave man he had
smilingly faced death
a dozen times in granite river prison
but always his danger was known to be
from living breathing men
abject terror gripped him now a nameless
terror that seemed to freeze the blood
in his veins
contract every muscle and nerve of his
body smother his heart
but even then reasoning struggled for
recognition in his mind
what if it were a part of us ashore's a
part of him that remained on earth to
defy death and carry on
hadn't assa always been captain dunlap's
friend
why should he fear the spirit of a
friend
dunlap reached forth a trembling hand
took the receiver from the hook
and slowly reluctantly placed it to his
ear
how he wished hoped prayed that no voice
would come over the wire
but it did come preceded by a faint
whispering sound
[Music]
a long pause then weakly almost
inaudibly
as if the message came from a million
miles away
[Music]
another pause a jumble of meaningless
words
then a chuckle god asa's familiar
chuckle
a light laugh a sharp buzzing sound a
sigh
the faint tinkle of a bell then silence
dunlap heard no click of a receiver
being replaced on a hook
the line was apparently still open still
holding the receiver to his ear
the captain moistened his dry lips with
the tip of his tongue
his free hand went involuntarily to his
forehead
in a vague uncertain gesture and came
away damp with perspiration
must he answer that ghost call must he
speak to that thing that held the line
when he at last spoke his voice was
husky
a strange voice even to him who
who did addassa if you were dead
if this is you asa tell me who did it
again that queer unfamiliar buzzing
sound
then from old tower number three or from
beyond the grave perhaps
came a faint whispering uncertain voice
the voice ended in a gurgle dunlap
replaced the receiver on the hook
and as he did so his eyes rested on the
indicator board
and he gasped sharply for the indicator
for old tower number three went wavering
trembling back to a vertical position
on the time dial this unheard of
behavior of the indicator was the
deepest mystery of all
the indicators each controlled
independently of the others by push
buttons in each tower
were constructed mechanically to turn
only from the right to left
the indicator for old tower number three
had turned back
from left to right captain dunlap made
no effort to solve the mystery
old tower number three was securely
locked and could not be approached
except by crossing over the wall from
new tower number three on the southeast
corner of the wall
or from tower number two on the
northeast corner of the wall
dunlap himself had closed and locked the
doors and windows to the tower
there was but one key to the tower doors
and that key
was in dunlap's pocket unlike the other
towers
old tower number three could not be
entered from the ground outside the wall
it was built solidly of stone from the
ground up and the only entrances were
the two doors communicating with the top
of the wall on either side of the tower
besides strict orders had been given
that no one entered the tower
unless ordered there by a shift captain
and two
in the glare of the arclights near the
wall it would be impossible for anyone
to cross the wall to the tower
without being seen by the other wall
guards
could the mysterious report have come
from one of the other wall towers
impossible for this reason when the push
button in one of the wall towers
say that an old tower number three was
pressed by the man on duty there
the indicator on the board and the
captain's lockout turned to the left a
quarter turn on the time dial
the small bell on the board rang and all
telephone connections with the other
towers were automatically cut off
until the captain had replaced the
telephone receiver on the hook
after receiving the report from old
tower number three
dunlap said nothing to bill wilton when
the latter returned to the yard lookout
after making his round in the yard it
would be best he reasoned
to say nothing to anybody about the
mysterious call
they would only laugh at him if he told
them about it
if the indicator had not returned to a
vertical position on the time dial
he would have some proof on which to
base his wild story of the ghost call
but the indicator had before his own
eyes returned to its former position
after the call an hour later at 2 am
dunlap fearfully watched the indicator
for old tower number three
reports from all other posts had been
received
then just once the indicator trembled
uncertainly made almost a quarter turn
to the left
and snapped back to a vertical position
at three o'clock
it did not move nor did it at four
o'clock
[Music]
a week passed not a tremor disturbed the
ghost tower indicator
then one morning at 1 30 an unearthly
piercing scream in the cell house
awakened half the men in the building
and sent the cell house guard
scurrying down to cell 21 on the
corridor for it was from this cell
that the blood-chilling scream had come
the bloodless perspiration-dampened face
of malcolm hulsey the lifer
was pressed against the bars of the cell
door when the guard arrived
the convict's great hands grasped the
bars and his 250 pound bulk
clad only in a regulation undershirt
twitched
started and trembled from head to foot a
horrible fear distended his eyes
his teeth clicked together and the
muscles of his face worked spasmodically
sick halsey the guard demanded hardened
to such nerve-shattering outbursts in a
building full of tortured souls
i saw i saw halsey began
his teeth chattering and rendering
speech well nigh impossible
i saw mr hill please give me a cellmate
now tonight i'm a sick man mr hill
nerves all shot to pieces i guess
can i have a cellmate to talk to mr hill
what did you see the guard asked
he was standing right where you are now
halsey whispered hoarsely
pointing his fingers at me he was when i
opened my eyes and saw him
smiling too i a violent shudder
i could see through him mr hill could
see the bars on that window beyond him
who see who the guard interrupted
halsey seemed to realize then that he
was talking too much
that he was not conducting himself as
the hardest convict in the prison should
why he stammered i saw
i thought i saw an old pal of mine he's
been dead a long time
nerves i guess thinking too much about
my old pal in the good old days
nightmare i guess yeah
nightmare is right the unsympathetic
guard growled
but don't let another blat like that out
of you or will throw you out into the
padded cell
got the whole wing stirred up get to bed
now and forget that good old pal of
yours
if only i could halsey whispered huskily
to himself
as he got back into the bunk two weeks
passed
there were no more outbursts from cell
21
the ghost tower on the wall was silent
cold
at two o'clock one morning captain
dunlap saw the indicator move
it sickened him made him wish ardently
that he was a thousand miles from
granite river prison
the indicator moved slowly hesitantly to
the left
and the bell tinkled weakly the captain
placed the receiver to his ear
but no sound came the line was dead
the indicator fell back to its original
position as the captain replaced the
receiver on the hook
a few minutes later the yard guard
entered the lookout
bill wilton the regular yard guard on
the graveyard shift
was away on leave and the substitute
guard was new at the position
didn't i understand you to say mr dunlap
the new guard said
that there was no one on old tower
number three you sure did
dunlap answered the guard pulled his
left ear and looked puzzled
funny he finally remarked i was sure i
heard somebody in that tower
singing soft and low-like when i passed
under it a few minutes ago
what was he singing the captain asked
bending forward and fixing a penetrating
gaze on the recent arrival at the prison
let me see now said the guard
meditatively
couldn't make out much of the song
something about when i die in the ocean
deep
no that wasn't it when i die and i'm
buried deep that's it
then there was something in it about
this dead guy coming back to haunt
people
and a lot of bunk like that i see
said dunlap as he eased himself out of
the chair
i'm going up and have a look around in
the tower you stay in here until i
return dunlap went outside the walls and
up through new tower number three
where he questioned guard jim humphrey
humphrey had not seen or heard anything
unusual
in or about old tower number three
captain dunlap as he walked over the
wall toward the ghost tower
admitted frankly to himself that he was
scared stiff
pausing at the door he glanced nervously
through the window
the yard lights lit up the interior of
the tower sufficiently to assure him
that no one
or thing was inside he unlocked the door
and entered
with a flashlight he thoroughly examined
the telephone
dust had settled on the instrument the
receiver in the transmitter had
apparently not been touched
since asa shores left the tower dust had
settled on the doorknobs inside
that the knobs had not been touched
since shores death was obvious
the one chair the windowsills the small
wash stand and wash basin
all were covered with a thin undisturbed
film of fine dust
there on the telephone battery box
reposed asa's old corn cob pipe
and near it a small box of matches the
window latches were just as dunlap had
left them
when he closed and securely locked the
tower a month before
it was a puzzled and nervous prison
official that left the tower
re-locked the doors and returned to the
inside lookout
the next day malcolm hulsey the lifer
was admitted to the hospital
the doctor's diagnosis was nervous
breakdown
but halsey though his nerves were all
shot to pieces
was still capable of shrewd plotting his
admittance to the hospital had been
hastened by a diet of soap
hulsey was so anxious to get far away
from granite river prison
and was so certain of his ability to do
so if he could only be admitted to the
hospital
that he had resorted to the old but
effective expedient of soap eating
soap taken internally in small doses
will produce various baffling and
apparently serious physiological changes
in the body
hulsey looked and felt sick but he was
not dangerously ill
for many months malcolm halsey had been
watching closely the movements of the
night guards
during his stay in the hospital while
recovering from the gunshot wound in his
shoulder
he had doped out a possible means of
escape and he was on the point of making
the attempt
when the doctor pronounced him
sufficiently recovered to be returned to
the cell house
the lifer's plan of escape was simply
this at midnight
while captain dunlap and his crew were
on duty the yard guard made his round
counted the patients in the hospital and
left the yard through the guard's gate
to eat his lunch in the guard's dining
room
outside the walls when the yard guard
returned to the inside lookout he
carried with him a hot lunch for captain
dunlap
in counting the men in the hospital the
yard guard did not as a rule
enter the building he merely turned on
the lights in one large ward
and looked through the window the
convict hospital nurse on night duty
stood ready
and when the lights were turned on
proceeded from bed to bed
and partly uncovered each patient so
that the yard guard outside could see
and count them
there were several factors in hulsey's
favor now one being that a new
substitute guard was on duty over the
guard's entrance gate during the absence
of the regular guard who was away on
vacation
there was only one patient in the
hospital besides hulsey
the yard guard must be lured into the
hospital overpowered
his uniform stripped from him then
halsey
garbed in the uniform would attempt to
deceive the guard at the gate
and be given the keys at 15 minutes to
midnight on hulsey's first day in the
hospital
the lifer quietly rose from his bed
while the white-clad convict nurse's
back was turned
three minutes later the unsuspecting
nurse had been neatly laid out from a
well-directed blow behind the ear
bound with sheets gagged stripped of his
white suit
and tenderly tucked in the bed recently
occupied by mr malcolm hulsey
the other patient a feeble old convict
was gagged and tied down in his bed with
sheets
hulsey then donned the nurse's white
suit and after arranging the nurse and
the old convict in their beds so that
they appeared to be sleeping peacefully
the lifer lay face down on the floor and
awaited developments
at 12 o'clock the new guard appeared at
the hospital window
and switched on the lights having
counted the med in the hospital every
hour since 8 o'clock
the guard intended now to give the
patients a hasty glance
and proceed to the gate there were his
two patients
apparently sleeping peacefully but where
was the nurse
halsey's heart pounded like a riveting
hammer as he lay sprawled on the floor
would the ruse work would the guard
enter the hospital to investigate
or would he report to captain dunlap
when he saw the white clad figure on the
floor
[Music]
the guard's eyes then rested on the man
on the floor
huh he exclaimed funny place for nursey
to be sleeping
but the nurse's sprawled form did not
indicate slumber
the guard was puzzled perhaps the nurse
had fainted
or fallen and hurt himself the guard
tapped on the window with a key
no answer no movement of nurse or
patience
then the unsuspecting screw unlocked the
door and entered
an older guard would have reported to
the captain
he was in the act of bending over to
turn the pseudo-nurse upon his back
when his ankles were suddenly seized and
his feet jerked from underneath him
the guard's head struck an iron bedstead
as he fell
thus relieving halsey of the unpleasant
job of beating him into unconsciousness
several minutes later the lifer wearing
the guard's uniform
boldly approached the gate what's on the
menu tonight frank
hulsey casually asked pulling his hat
further down over his eyes
same old thing hash the gate guard
answered as he lowered the keys
though the suspense anxiety and
uncertainty were terrible
hulsey whistled calmly as he unlocked
the first gate
the large bull lock on the outside gate
was not so easily unlocked
halsey fumbled his hands shook in spite
of all he could do to keep it up
wheezed and went off key then died in a
discordant whale
say the gate guard suddenly blurted look
up here
by cracky your actions don't look good
to me
halsey did not look up he gave the key
another frantic twist
and the lock opened in that short space
of time the wall guard had raced into
the lookout and seized a shotgun
as he stepped to the door of the lookout
a dark figure disappeared around the
corner of a building
20 feet from the gate a moment later the
alarm in the guard's quarters rang
frantically
and a dozen sleepy-eyed men tumbled from
their beds
slipped on shoes and trousers and ran
out into the yard
the gate guard can only tell where he
last saw the escaping convict
to capture the man on such a dark knight
seemed hopeless
considering too that the fleeing man had
a seven minute start
however the half-dressed guards
scattered and made for the heavy willow
thicket several hundred yards beyond the
spot where the convict was last seen
for five minutes after the pursuing
guards disappeared in the darkness
silence reigned over the prison then
from a distant point in the dark thicket
a hair-raising
half-animal half-human shriek of mortal
terror
shattered the stillness of the night and
echoed and re-echoed about the high
prison walls
white-faced guards temporarily unnerved
by that fearful whale
crashed through the brush their
flashlights playing about like the eyes
of speeding demons
then they found malcolm hulsey the lifer
groveling face down in the mud of a
little creek bank
hands clutching at empty air great
spasms of maniacal terror passing
through his body
the one-time terror of the prison
muttered insane incoherent things
two guards pulled him to his knees
others turned flashlights on his face
a face such as his scene in horrible
nightmares a ghastly face
partly covered with black mud the eyes
were wide protruding
glassy see see the convict rasped
hoarsely
pointing a mud-smeared hand at a dense
black nook in the thicket
see he stands there and points at me and
laughs
it's assa shores he's been in my cell
every night for
weeks laughing at me he sang a death
song to me
always saying always laughed wouldn't
let me sleep
he's coming toward me stop him please
then another horrible shriek a shudder a
gasp
and the guards dropped the lifeless form
of malcolm hulsey in the mud
[Music]
by some queer whim of fate the
speechless guards involuntarily switched
off their flashlights
utter darkness utter silence enveloped
them
then a faint sound was heard listen
came the hoarse voice of guard jerry
clark do you hear it
very little of it could be heard it was
a faint sound
and growing fainter
then it was gone and all was still again
you